bonjour et bienvenue en check up le
magazine santé de la rédaction au
sommaire ce mois-ci tout d'abord le rôle
et les missions d'un centre de
planification familiale il en existe 26
dans le département le diabète en france
trois millions et demi de personnes sont
concernées par cette maladie et 500000
s'ignorent alors les associations
organisent et les dépistages
nous irons à la découverte d'une salle
qui porte un drôle de nom snowdon une
salle pour apaiser les souffrances des
personnes âgées est tout d'abord le don
du sang l'établissement français du don
du sang organise régulièrement des
collectes auprès des particuliers mais
également dans les milieux
professionnels et nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre en mairie de trappes
les employés municipaux étaient invités
à donner leur sang
donner son sang n'est pas un acte anodin
il peut sauver des vies
l'établissement français du sang d'île
de france a organisé une collecte dans
les locaux de la mairie de trappes sur
les civières personnel de la commune et
trappistes pour habiba c'était la
première fois une expérience qui s'est
bien passé et qu'elle souhaite réitérer
à l'avenir je venais me donner un peu de
sens pour les gens qui ont besoin tant
qu'on est en bonne santé je préfère
donner aux gens qui ont besoin les gens
qui ont des accidents sur la route des
maladies graves lacunes et en janvier
mais c'est dommage qu'il ait une fois
puis souvent ces deux bénévoles non non
pas depuis des années 60 dont déjà dans
montre ma carte en globules rouges
plaquettes plasma des dons
indispensables pour permettre la
guérison de maladies comme la leucémie
ou la drépanocytose une maladie
génétique de l'hémoglobine qui nécessite
une transfusion sanguine par semaine dès
le plus jeune âge des dons qui
permettent aussi de donner des
traitements de qualité aux patients
globalement depuis le début de l'année
sur les yvelines où ce secteur dont ja
responsabilité mais essentiellement les
yvelines ça se passe très bien
parce que nous sommes au-dessus de nos
objectifs plus particulièrement nous
avons connu un mois de
de septembre et d'octobre pas très bon
et là cette semaine est pas bonne du
tout puisque grosso modo quand on attend
100 donneurs d'habitude il ya 95 qu'il
présente et là on est plutôt au niveau
70 en ile-de-france 1700 dons par jour
sont nécessaires
4 dont maximum par an pour les femmes et
6 pour les hommes mais les trappistes
eux ont été généreux ce jour-là 73
donneurs ont répondu présent au lieu des
60 attendu
voilà et puis notez ces deux rendez vous
que vous fixe l'établissement français
du don du sang le 6 décembre en gare de
versailles rive droite et le 14 décembre
à l'espace saint quentin à montigny
alors connaissez-vous les centres de
planification familiale à ne pas
confondre avec le planning familial ce
sont des endroits où l'on peut trouver
toutes sortes de réponses à des
questions liées à la sexualité
ces centres sont au nombre de 26 dans le
département et ils sont gérés par le
conseil général il existe 26 centres de
planification familiale dans les
yvelines géré par le conseil général
comme ici à trappes dans ces lieux une
équipe composée d'un médecin et d'une
conseillère conjugale et familiale
conseil qui veut sur la sexualité offre
un accès à la contraception et au
dépistage des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles
on parle souvent de libération des
moeurs et pourtant face à ces
questionnements
rien n'a vraiment changé chez des jeunes
la sexualité ça reste un sujet tabou
ça reste un sujet difficile à aborder
soit parce que les parents veulent pas
en entendre parler ou ne peuvent pas
entendre parler enfin les jeunes et soit
parce que parfois les jeunes ne veulent
pas en parler parce que c'est leur
intimité
ils savent beaucoup plus de choses ils
ont ils ont toujours du mal à mettre en
pratique
mais ils savent ils savent des choses
ils savent que la pilule ex tous les
mois une contraception icaunaise qui
connaissent les préservatifs la mise
le passage à l'acte à la mise en
pratique est plus compliqué les centres
de planification familiale à ne pas
confondre avec le planning familial qui
est une association sont mal connus des
jeunes générations
et pourtant ici les entretiens sont
gratuits et confidentiels
un colloque sur ce thème s'est déroulée
à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'adulte et un
rôle important à jouer dans la
transmission des informations c'est le
message de ce professeur il ya moins
d'autorité naturelle et surtout les
beaucoup d'adultes de se sentent plus
légitime au fonds d'intervenir c'est
peut-être là ils sous estiment
l'importance qu'ils ont pour les ados
beaucoup d'adolescents sensibles ont
peur de la déception est à la place il
s'enferme dans des comportements qu'ils
pensent maîtriser mais qui en général
les empêche de se nourrir justement des
échanges qu'il est pour elle et
valoriser leur donner confiance en 2011
les 26 centres de planification des
yvelines ont reçu 8500 personnes est
assurée 14000 consultation un projet est
en cours pour diminuer le nombre de ses
centres mais leur permettre d'être
ouvert du lundi au vendredi ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
le diabète est une maladie invisible qui
touche en france trois millions et demi
de personnes un chiffre alarmant
cinq cent mille personnes s'ignorent et
notamment les jeunes enfants qui sont de
plus en plus atteints en raison
notamment de mauvaises habitudes
alimentaires
une piqûre sur le bout du doigt même pas
le temps de prendre sa respiration et
c'est fait martine clerc est venu tester
son taux de sucre dans le sang son
niveau de diabète
parce que la dernière fois j'avais se
trouvait à tous un petit peu élevé le
matin aja par le laboratoire
donc j'ai voulu re contrôlé alors ça a
donné quoi ah ben c'est parfait
aujourd'hui c'est parfait 110 donc ça
doit être mon pour quelqu'un qui vient
de cas des jeunes et il ya moins de deux
heures donc c'est parfait
moi aussi c'est parfait elles ont le
sourire tant mieux en france on estime à
3 millions et demi le nombre de
diabétiques dont 500000 signoret les
risques sont pourtant réels on va avoir
tous les risques cardiovasculaires tous
les risques va justement dans quand on
parle de risque cardiovasculaire et de
complications ça va forcément tous et
tous les petits vaisseaux et gros
vaisseaux et donc entraîner des
problèmes que ce soit au niveau des yeux
au niveau des reins au niveau du coeur
il existe deux types de diabète le
diabète de type 1 qui touche les enfants
et les adolescents et le diabète de type
2 qui concerne les plus de 40 ans mais
qui atteint de plus en plus de jeunes en
cause la sédentarité et la malbouffe les
conseils de prévention sont évidents
d'avoir une activité physique
d'équilibrer ses repas
ce qui n'est pas facile pour tous un vu
de la conjoncture actuelle que nous
rencontrons dans la société pour nos
jeunes diabétiques c'est avoir un
équilibre puisque pour le diabète de
type 1 malheureusement nos jeunes sont
tout de suite traité par insuline
donc c'est d'adapter leur traitement à
leur vie de tous les jours
et de continuer à vivre normalement avec
une hygiène de vie
le diabète est une maladie du pancréas
elle est invisible mais il ya des signes
qui doivent prévenir comme incertaine
amaigrissement une soif importante
un besoin d'uriner et un manque
d'attention pour les plus jeunes enfants
le nom est abstrait snozelen en fait
c'est la contraction d'un mot
néerlandais qui signifie explorer et
somnoler et des salles de ce type voient
le jour notamment dans les maisons de
retraite à leurs reportages au centre
gérontologique de chevreuse
un espace fermé et protégé aux lumières
tamisées une musique d'ambiance une
guirlande bleu des petites lampes
blanches et vertes au plafond jean-paul
pitois souffrent de handicap sur ce
matelas haut il se relaxent la technique
porte un nom snowdon et les séances
durent entre 30 et 40 minutes
voilà c
et y'a pas brillé super on a plus
l'impression d'être à l'hôpital avec
monsieur pitois c'est plus de la
relaxation avec un travail au niveau du
matelas à eau qui est celui de détente
et des mobilisations des massages avec
les balles après il ya d'autres
résidents où on est plus sur le
sensoriel donc à travailler avec les
fibres optiques le plafond lumineux
il ya des résidents qui sont très fermés
sur eux-mêmes et ça c'est vraiment un
espace où il s'ouvre aux autres et à la
relation
la méthode snoezelen de la contraction
de deux mots hollandais qui signifie
explorer et somnoler existe depuis 1970
aux pays bas en france ces salles ont
fait leur apparition dans les années 90
réserver aussi bien aux malades
d'alzheimer qu'aux personnes atteintes
de troubles moteurs ou cérébraux même
s'ils peuvent pas le dire parce qu'il ya
quand même des personnes qui viennent
ici qui ne peuvent pas exprimer avec des
mots mais on voit vraiment physiquement
la détente c'est renier tout pour ceux
qui ne peuvent pas quitter leur chambre
il existe un dispositif mobile
tout cela a un coût 13 1500 euros
financés intégralement pour cet hôpital
par le rotary club la santé est une
mission les enfants handicapés c'est une
mission
le
disons que le leitmotiv du rotary servir
d'abord la salle est installé depuis le
mois de juin une vingtaine de patients
bénéficient et de l'avis des
professionnels qui encadrent le
dispositif
tous les résidents se sont montrés très
réceptifs aller avant de nous quitter
noter ces rendez vous sentez une
conférence débat aura lieu le mardi 11
décembre sur le thème stress angoisse
dépression des thèmes pas très joyeux
mais malheureusement d'actualité une
conférence animée par le docteur ce
galop centre socioculturel des merisiers
attrape le 13 décembre ce sera un
atelier santé actifs proposés par la
ceppm sur le thème bien manger sans se
ruiner
et puis l'unafam l'union des familles et
amis de malades psychiques propose de
son côté une conférence le 26 janvier
sur le thème comment faire face au
sentiment de culpabilité chez cup c'est
fini merci de votre attention prochain
rendez-vous du magazine santé ce sera le
4 janvier 2013
d'ici là passer d'excellentes fêtes de
fin d'année des petits excès mais rien
de plus
et surtout portez vous bien
là